the original Star Wars trilogy remains
one of the most successful and popular
film series in history so when it came
time to cast the prequels in the late
90s George Lucas had a tall task ahead
of him and his casting choices didn't
always pan out whether you love or hate
the Star Wars prequels though there's no
denying the franchise might have been
very different if some of the big-name
stars Lucas had considered were in the
films instead here's a look at some of
the a-list celebrities who were almost
in the Star Wars prequels Leonardo
DiCaprio as Anakin Skywalker
by the time Attack of the Clones began
filming in 2000 Leonardo DiCaprio had
become the hottest young heartthrob in
Hollywood with films like Titanic
DiCaprio met with Lucas about playing
Anakin Skywalker and the second and
third Star Wars prequels but ultimately
turned down the role because despite his
superstar status he didn't feel ready
for the kind of attention that Star Wars
would bring it was the second time he
almost romance Natalie Portman on screen
she was originally cast opposite
DiCaprio in Romeo and Juliet but dropped
out because she was so young at the time
that her scenes with DiCaprio were
unintentionally creepy good thing she
avoided all that creepy romance right oh
wait
I'm haunted by the kiss that you should
never have given me my heart is beating
hoping that that kiss will not become a
scar whoops
Christian Bale as Anakin Skywalker years
before Christian Bale done Batman's
iconic cape and cowl he was almost a
very different type of Dark Knight in
the lead up to Attack of the Clones
Lucasfilm casting director Robin
Guerlain reviewed over 700 tapes
hoping to find the perfect Anakin
Skywalker one name that reportedly came
up Christian Bale who had worked with
George Lucas's close friends Steven
Spielberg on Empire of the Sun and was
coming off a critically acclaimed
performance as a gleefully murderous
businessman in 2000 American Psycho the
role went to Hayden Christensen instead
however Oh what might have been talking
about nothing
yeah everything's cool man Colin Hanks
as Anakin Skywalker like DiCaprio and
Bale Colin Hanks son of Tom Hanks also
lost the role of Anakin Skywalker to
Hayden Christensen the reason because
Christensen's chemistry with Portman who
has already cast a play Queen Amidala
was apparently too good to miss thanks
probably dodged a bullet he has a
thriving career while Kristen
is known as the guy who ruins Darth
Vader the feeling is mutual buddy tupac
shakur as mace windu the role of mace
windu seem to have been written
specifically for lifelong Star Wars fans
samuel l.jackson but before jackson got
the part lucas actually auditioned other
actors for the role including legendary
rapper Tupac Shakur according to Rick
Clifford an audio engineer at Death Row
Records who often spoke with Tupac about
the rapper's budding acting career Tupac
auditioned for Lucas sometime in 1996
shortly before the Phantom Menace
started filming unfortunately Tupac died
in a still unresolved drive-by shooting
later that year Jackson ended up with
the part and the rest is history this
party food Benicio del Toro as Darth
Maul if there's a single good thing that
came out of the Phantom Menace its Darth
Maul the guy looks cool uses a super
cool double lightsaber and actually made
brief moments of the film watchable
before newcomer Rey Park took over the
role Benicio del Toro was cast as the
spiky Sith Lord but del Toro who has a
face built for villainy left the role
when George Lucas cut out most of them
all speaking parts leaving only a lot of
fancy gymnastics good news though del
Toro will be returning to the Star Wars
universe in Episode eight Michael
Jackson as Jar Jar Binks of course for
all the good that Darth Maul brought
there's this guy yes Jar Jar Binks that
infamous weirdo from another planet is
unquestionably the most controversial
character in the Star Wars universe now
imagine how much more controversial he
would have been if he had been played by
Michael Jackson that infamous weirdo
from another planet yes it's true while
the Phantom Menace was being filmed in
London Lucas introduced charger actor
Ahmed best to Michael Jackson and as it
turned out
Jackson had one of the role first
Michael was kind of lobbying for the
role he really wanted to do it but he
wanted to do with like prosthetics manka
Lucas wanted to create a fully
computer-generated character however so
he cast best in a role instead at least
we'll always have Captain EO
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]